hey what's up you guys Denny here this
is the daily daddy I'm hanging out with
Ashe crossing it look where we are
comic-con our Super Bowl very exciting
so exciting in fact behind us is the
actual San Diego Convention Center where
the con is taking place as I mentioned
it's your Super Bowl
are you throwing about a super sweaty in
there and I know my hair is not
surviving this humidity I'm a little but
yeah because I'm is right I feel the
buzz building there's already been huge
breaking news huge panels I mean we've
got that 6,500 coveted Hall H panel and
there's been some fun fun moments that's
only day one guys we are expecting over
a hundred and thirty thousand people to
walk these streets that's a lot of
people it's a lot of people around and
I'll tell you what Ashley I wasted no
time yesterday we got a inside look
achtung good place activation which is
right behind us and yet we apologize
because we're real extra immediately
delirious particularly we made it to the
good place Sid we though it's literally
day one that's true
hey guys we are taking you inside the
activation of the NBC hit show here at
comic-con yeah why can't I say Fork
oh come on now yeah I see popcorn this
is my happy place it looks exactly like
the show cool we're alone in the good
place we did it what's something like
ice cream that's not as good Froyo let's
get Froyo
[Music]
well over here we have perhaps my
favorite character she well this isn't
actually um there's actually a
chalkboard but here's my compass we're
doing her best but that makes sense why
there are some shrimp up in here I must
be messing up we love shrimp I really
love shrimp dip me in some cocktail
sauce
I would like shrimp cocktail hope a
shrimp shrimp it's what's for dinner I'm
actually allergic to shellfish so are
you know that was riveting how did you
feel riding a shrimp on to see I'm
hungry we didn't fight cocktails but we
did find the next best thing real not
real not real cool well that was a blast
and Ashley talked to Ted Danson and he
says we can go back to earth what yeah
one more shot let's try it
I'm gonna dancing my way over that huh
as you can tell we are out of our minds
there a little bit I'm so sorry about
that
all right all right we can't talk about
some panels though because as you
mentioned there's a recent news come out
of them
oh my gosh well fur you know for me my
biggest breaking news thus far has been
Star Wars did this like tiny non Hall H
panel where they acted like they weren't
gonna say anything and it's gonna be a
ten year anniversary of Clone Wars and
then they were like psyche trailer or
bringing Clone Wars back to our
streaming service huge breaking news the
crowd went insane and everybody is
talking about love that speaking of
panels everybody's talking about the big
one today was the creditor huge cast
sternly kept out Livia Mun
keegan-michael key trivanti Russ
Jacob Tremblay Jacob tries my favorite
I'm a lot of stuff come another way yes
super cute moments with Olivia Munn and
sterling kate brown and you know
keegan-michael key Olivia said that
those two should have run for [ __ ] run
cuz you guys 2020 if you recall the
original predator Arnold Schwarzenegger
ran for governor so anyone can run for
office apparently I want to do it what
do you mean I get it I think I'm gonna
get it she's gunning for Sterling and
Keegan except sterling said that might
be too much blackness
I disagree disagree I say we need you
all right guys well that's it for today
you guys from the daily Denny tomorrow
we'll be back right here I'm sharing
with you guys all the news coming out of
the big TV panels as well be here too
we'll probably get into some other
trouble in fact I'm gonna head down to
the conference again just [ __ ] man again
wish me luck all right guys thank you so
much for watching make sure you guys are
subscribed to e t--'s youtube channel
following the daily danny on facebook
watch i'll see you guys tomorrow